activasys is a collection of tools and
services that simplify your resource
management experience on google cloud
in this video we're going to show you
three recommenders that will help you
zero in on the opportunities to save on
the costs operating in google cloud the
idle virtual machine or vm recommender
the vm machine type recommender and the
unattended project recommender let's get
into it
on google cloud compute engine you can
spin up virtual machines and you'll only
be billed for the time that each is
running this pay-as-you-go model is one
of the best benefits of building your
infrastructure in the cloud
at the same time if your project has
lots of virtual machines costs can add
up over time you'll be paying for those
resources whether you're actively using
them or not
to avoid paying for resources that
you're not using there's two things
you'll want to make sure of
first ensure that every machine that's
running in your project is being put to
good use
and second make sure that the virtual
machines you're running have the
appropriate resource allocations such as
the number of virtual cpus and the size
of the memory
for example you'll probably like to know
whether the vm running in your
development environment is still being
used or if it was just a test machine
that someone accidentally forgot to turn
off or delete
and if it is being used you want to be
confident that it has just the right
resources configured for the intended
workload
you could do an audit yourself to figure
these things out but if you're looking
at number of projects each with multiple
virtual machines multiple users teams
applications this can quickly become a
labor-intensive approach
this is where a couple of recommenders
can help drastically simplify the
experience to help avoid paying for
things that you're not using
first the idle vm recommender will
highlight vms that haven't recently been
used so you can shut them down or delete
them from your project
the recommendations for idle vms are
based on system metrics that are
gathered by the cloud monitoring service
over the past 14 days
for new machines this starts a few days
after creation
a vm is classified as idle when all
three of these criteria are met
cpu utilization is less than .03 for 97
of the vm runtime
received network traffic is less than
2600 bytes per second for 95 percent of
the vm runtime and sent network traffic
is less than a thousand bytes per second
for 95 of the vm runtime with these
criteria met a vm is identified as idle
it's up to you to decide whether to keep
it running shut it down or delete it
completely from your project
if you shut it down it'll stop
recruiting costs plus you can always
start it back up if you need it again in
the future
so that's idle vms but how can active
assist help with costs on machines that
aren't idle
well along with the idle vm recommender
you'll also see recommendations from the
vm machine type recommender these
recommendations are also known as right
sizing recommendations because they're
all about finding the right size for
your workloads
rightsizing recommendations are
generated by monitoring the cpu and
memory utilization of running vms for
the last eight days
this data helps you identify if the
machines are not efficiently using all
of their allocated resources with that
the recommender can suggest a more
appropriate machine type for that
virtual machine
let's say that you have an application
running on an n2 standard 16 instance
that machine type has 16 virtual cpus
and 64 gigabytes of memory if your
application generally uses most of the
cpu but never really uses more than 16
gigabytes of memory you might get a
right sizing recommendation to use an n2
high cpu 16 instead this machine type
has the same number of virtual cpus but
has a lot less memory and an overall
lower hourly price
when right sizing recommendations are
made for machines with less resource
usage than they have allocated applying
them results in a reduction in costs
without impacting your performance
the savings will multiply with every
virtual machine that you're able to
downsize based on these recommendations
virtual machines aren't the only source
of costs though
other cost cutting recommenders include
the committed use discount recommender
the idle custom image recommender the
idle ip address recommender and the idle
persistent disk recommender
beyond those resources the unattended
project recommender will help you
identify projects that are potentially
unused so they can be reviewed or
deleted this is especially valuable if
you're an administrator for an entire
organization with lots of projects
there's a good chance some of those
projects could have cloud resources that
are accruing costs even though they're
not actively being used the way it works
is by analyzing project usage data over
the last 30 days for any project with
low usage in that period of time and for
which there are no oauth tokens used in
the last 180 days you'll receive a
recommendation to review or delete the
project
when you delete a project you're also
deleting all of the resources in that
project that you're being billed for
this recommender also lets you take a
proactive approach to managing projects
by identifying projects that still have
usage but whose owners are not active on
the project
for those projects you'll get a
recommendation to reclaim the project by
assigning someone else's the owner this
can help prevent projects from becoming
unattended in the first place by making
sure that there's someone accountable
for each of them
now let me show you how simple it is to
discover and apply some recommendations
from the recommendation hub with a few
clicks
in this scenario i've got the compute
recommender admin iam role assigned so
that i can view and manage idle vm and
machine type recommendations
i also have the compute admin iam role
so that i'm able to apply the changes in
those recommendations
on top of those i'm also using the cloud
spanner viewer role to view the cpu
utilization graphs included with the vm
machine type recommendations
now that we're in the google cloud
console the first place we might notice
recommendations for our virtual machines
is the compute engine vm instances page
this page will show all of the virtual
machines associated with your project
there's a summary at the top of the page
and individual recommendations next to
the corresponding instance
we can see these same recommendations
over in the recommendation hub
let's start with the recommendations
from the idle vm recommender
here in the list of recommendations
we'll see each recommendation the
instance it corresponds to and the
recommended action
directly from here we can click any
recommendation and perform the
recommended action in this case shutting
down the instance
if stopping the instance isn't an option
for us this machine has another
recommendation to switch the machine
type let's stop this vm for
now let's take a look at the
recommendation from the vm machine type
recommender
this time we'll see the recommendation
the corresponding instance the
recommended machine type and the current
machine type
when we click on one of the
recommendations we'll be able to see a
more complete view of the recommended
configuration
if we choose we could adjust the
recommended configuration and add more
memory or cores
after reviewing a recommendation if we
decide it isn't applicable we can simply
dismiss it to have it removed from the
recommendation hub and stop receiving
the recommendation
otherwise we can accept the
recommendation and apply it from here
note that this will shut down the
instance briefly so make sure there's
redundancy in place or that you're
working within a designated maintenance
window
once the instance restarts on the new
machine type the corresponding
recommendation will be marked as applied
in your recommendation history
all of the active assist recommendations
we've talked about are designed to
highlight opportunities to take action
on things that could be difficult to
keep track of otherwise especially when
you're working with hundreds or even
thousands of resources across many
projects
idle vm and right sizing recommendations
help find resources that aren't being
used but that you're still paying for
even better the unattended project
recommendations will likely tell you
which projects aren't being used
and remember recommendations are exactly
what they sound like recommendations
we call these features recommenders
because there's no one better than you
at knowing the full details and best
steps to take and the recommendations
are only there to help you identify
opportunities to dig deeper
you can check out the documentation to
try these out for yourself and don't
forget about the recommendation hub
where you can see all sorts of helpful
recommendations
stay tuned for the next video where
we'll look at some more recommendations
that will help you improve another
important factor performance
see you there
you